الذكاء الاصطناعي الفتره الماضيه شغل
العالم الشاغل خاصه من بعض ظهور تشاد جي
بي تي وتحول لي التطبيق الاكثر نموا في
العالم في ناس جالسه تستعملوا وتشكر فيه
اناس بتستعمله بس بتقول انه الموضوع يخوف
وفي فريق خايف جدا ومرعوب وبيحذروا من انه
قال الاء هذه حتسيطر علينا لكن على
الناحيه الثانيه في ناس كمان مختصه بتطمن
الجميع وبتقول ما في شيء من هذا الكلام
اخرهم حتى من كم يوم ضيفنا مختص في
التكنولوجيا لكن امس الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه اوبن اي اي المطوره
طلع في تصريح امام مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
صدم العالم تماما
طبعا بالدرجه الاولى لازم نسمع الكلام
اللي تدار في مجلس الشيوخ نفسه يعني كان
يمكن على قمه الاولويات عندهم ان
الانتخابات ما تتضرر لان احنا نعرف
في السابق يعني اثرت على الانتخابات بشكل
كبير بس تخيلي الان عندنا ذكاء اصطناعي
يتدخل في الانتخابات
ويوصل رسائل موجهه لكل شخص يعني انا اذا
اتفاعل مع الذكاء الاصطناعي والمعلومات
هذه ياخذونها عني انا ولو كنت انا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وراح انتخب
اللي راح يصير ايش ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يوجه لي رساله لان يعرف طبيعتي شلون صايره
يوجه لي اياها بطريقه انسانيه يعني ساره
احنا عندنا مشكله كبيره الانسان يتاثر
يعني يعيش بالكلام ويموت بالكلام يعيش
بلغه ويموت باللغه تاثر بسرعه ولذلك
الانتخابات تاثر
يعني هذا الشيء اللي احنا ما نتمنى انه
يصير ولذلك قاعدين يحولون يفكرون كيف نضع
لوائح لهذا الموضوع حتى نضمن ان الوظائف
ما تروح طبعا لا ننسى هناك وظائف جديده
ستتكون بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن نريد
موازنه لا نريد ان نفقد الوظائف اخرى
خليني اقول لك دكتور محمد يعني انت الان
لما بتتكلم على موضوع الانتخابات صحيح
والوظائف صحيح بس هدول النقطتين تحديدا
كمان نتكلم عنهم اللي هو رئيس الشركه ومع
ذلك وقال انه قد او انه حتلغي وظائف وتظهر
وظائف جديده ومع ذلك قال انه ستضر العالم
بالضبط شوفي الحين الضرر الاساسي من شيء
مثل
هو تاثيره في
انتاج ماده فيها اشاعات فيها اضطرابات
فيها تاثير نحن نتاثر بالكلمه بسرعه فلذلك
ممكن دول تستغل هذه الفكره في انها توجه
رسائل للناس والشعوب رسائل مزيفه الشعوب
للتاثير عليها حتى تسقط مثلا حكوماتها حتى
تغير من اشياء معينه في نظام عملها فلذلك
هذا يعني هذا يعتبر واحد من مخاوف
الرئيسيه خصوصا يعني نحن نعرف الان الصراع
موجود بين الدول الكبرى وهذا راح ياثر
اكيد شغالين على هذا الموضوع بشكل جاد
حاليا طيب بس الان لما هو بيقول انه بيحذر
من هذا الموضوع
وبيطالب الكونغرس كمان انه يتم وضع قيود
او محاذير او اليه للتعامل مع هذا الموضوع
بدوره كان بيقولوا احنا تاخرنا في موضوع
مواقع التواصل خلينا نلحق الذكاء
الاصطناعي قبل ما نتاخر فيه يعني
واقعيا احنا شفنا موضوع اللي صار في
التواصل الاجتماعي واقعيا هل يمكن اصلا
وضع قيود للسيطره على الذكاء الاصطناعي
السؤال انا اعتقد هذا يمكن اهم سؤال لان
فعليا
الذكاء الاصطناعي الان يخرج لجميع الناس
والكثير من الناس تقدر تستخدمه يعني ليس
مثل انه يكون عندنا نووي اللي ما حد يقدر
يصنعه بسهوله او مثلا السلاح البيولوجي
اللي تحتاجين الى معامل لصناعته
مثلا يحتاج الى كمبيوترات كبيره لكن حتى
اصنع ذكاء اصطناعي بسيط هو في متناول يد
الجميع اليوم تدخلين على النت تقدرين
تاخذين الذكاء الاصطناعي تحطينه على
الكمبيوتر الشخصي
وتفعلينه
السيطره اعتقد امر صعب لكن لا ننسى ان
الفكر الاساسي للذكاء الاصطناعي وتطويره
وخصوصا الذكاء الاعقد اللي هو او الاكثر
تعقيدا اللي هو الذكاء العامل الصناعي هذا
لا يزال بيد الشركات وبيد الجهات المؤسس
اللي فيها ابحاث علميه وتحتاج الى عقول
قويه جدا فايضا لا يزال هناك مجال للتحكم
في هذا الجانب بحيث ان اذا اي شركه تمادت
او
اخرجت ذكاء الاصطناعي ما في سيطره تضع
عليها قيود وتضع عليها شروط او توقف عملها
بحيث انها ما تستطيع ان تستمر في مثل هذا
العمل بس مره اخرى اؤكد ان انا لا اظن
شخصيا ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن السيطره
عليه لان الان خرج من الفانوس وهو الان
موجود بايدي الكثير من الناس يعني هو
بيختلفوا معك بعض الناس وتحديدا يمكن في
الف شخصيه بارزه كمان وقعوا رساله اذا
تذكر يعني دكتور من ضمنهم ايلون ماسك
بيطالبوا فيها
بوقف تطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي حتى يتم وضع
المحاذير والكلام هذا كله بس ما اعرف صحيح
يعني بما انك يعني كلامك اللي هو قلته انه
يعني فعلا اصبح مفتوح للجميع بامكان
الجميع تطويره حاليا فخلص اعتقد المارد
خرج
بالضبط
خلينا نقول نريد ان نوازل الامور نريد ان
نضع اللوائح نريد ان نضبط الموضوع ولكن لا
نخف الى هذه الدرجه بحيث انه لا نستطيع ان
نعمل لا نستطيع ان نطور
المواقع التواصل يعني في لها اضرار لكن
استفدنا منها استفاده ايضا كبيره في
حياتنا طيب نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا من الكويت دكتور محمد قاسم عضو
مجلس اداره المدرسه الرقميه والاستاذ
السابق في كليه الدراسات التكنولوجيه شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]